in today's cloud minute I'll show you  how to create a Postgres instance via  cloud launcher starting on the cloud  launcher homepage click database  and then click Postgres  click Launch on Google cloud platform  pick the project where you'd like to  Postgres instance to be created and then  click the continue button  it may take a couple minutes for the  next screen to appear you will see a  progress bar indicating that it is  initializing give the VM a name and  configure it in a way that makes sense  for your project  then click create again launching the  instance may take a couple minutes note  the username and password click SSH to  log into the machine using the in  browser terminal now your Postgres  instance is created  let's check out our other cloud minutes